hello friends
how's it going
thanks for
seeing me again today if you if you
didn't see me if you slept in the real
developers sleep in
and didn't come to the talk this morning
this one is going to talk about
linux on windows
and uh who is using wsl today
so you know all this stuff you don't
even know why you're here you know all
this stuff
so this is great so we have a
medium-sized room small number of people
this is good and we have folks that have
been using wsl
before and you've seen the youtube
videos you've used it in your daily life
so if you have something to add
if i make a mistake or you have a tip
so that we can convert the others
that did not raise their hands so that
they might see the light
are you waiting to be converted or are
you going to convert people
so you're already you're already sold
okay cool because it's the year have you
heard it's the year of linux on the
desktop
the windows desktop yeah
where where the sound card works
it's good
all right cool
so i don't um believe in slides so we're
not going to do any slides we'll spend
some time in notepad here
and
we'll uh we'll talk about a bunch of
different things
but i want to provide a little bit of
historical context
so there was a thing called wsl1 and
then there was wsl2
and now it's just wsl so two is now
not one but two is just wsl
so wsl1
the windows subsystem for linux which
really should have been called the linux
subsystem for windows it's not really
clear why they didn't do that there's
some rule some legal thing
wsl one
was really interesting because it
introduced a concept called pico
processes
tiny processes did anyone use wsl1
back in the day
okay good it was okay
it worked fine
and the deal was that there's different
kinds of binaries right and uh some of
my
are there any linux people here like
old-time linux fees linux you're like
did you not want were you afraid we
would attack you
he was like
oh ooh i guess no one else is raising
their hand
so i i did linux like in the late 90s
like when it started right and then did
anyone uh do courseware in university
where you had to use minix
you ever heard of minix m-i-n-yeah so
minix was literally the thing that
started linux it was a tiny unix system
and you would get a book
the big thick hardback book in
university and you would have to write
the source code for
this tiny mini unix
and then you would get for your for your
operating systems class you would get
homework like write a file system
it's not quite the same as make a
website but it was it was our homework
and uh and then linus torvalds who
actually lives in my town in oregon
uh took that concept of minix and then
he ran with it and then that's where
linux came from so i've been a unix head
for you know for 30 years
so there's different kinds of binaries
right the uh if i make a dos binary dos
binary still exist on on windows the
first two bytes of a windows binary is
mz
and i think the guys like mike zawinski
or something literally the first two
bytes of the windows executable format
are this dude named mike's initials
because he was the guy like that was
he made it so he got to put his initials
there and that was
how that got that way and i thought that
was kind of an interesting flex
to to do that um
dos mz executable header
mike mark mark zabowski
isn't that great
why because
he just put 4d 5a so like that's the
header that you look for when you want
to start up an executable now
binaries on linux are called elf
binaries and they're a different kind of
binary
and when you have your machine you have
user mode and you have kernel mode right
the kernel mode is where all your
drivers run and then user mode is where
your apps run
and what wsl one did is it took the
ability to have elf binaries linux
binaries that i could copy from another
machine
and i could then run them and then every
time we went from user mode into kernel
mode
that moment
windows would lie
to the binary
okay let's think about think about this
we don't really think about this when
we're working on regular apps right
but when someone opens a socket or
someone opens a file handle who does
that it's not the app that does it the
app requests for the server open a port
to the kernel open a port
give me a file handle let me let me talk
to this piece of hardware those are all
kernel calls in windows we call them
kernel calls
or you call win32
and in linux they call them syscalls or
system calls and there's a big system
called table and there's like the 80
percent case of like here's the top 150
syscalls
and then there's the long tail of
syscalls which is like here's the other
650
something like eight or nine hundred
systems so what wsl one did is you would
take an elf binary directly up a linux
machine in user mode and it could like
you know open up a file and print
something out to the screen
that's the job of that that binary so
that means it needs to open a file
handle seek on the disk within that file
receive those strings and then output
them to the console sounds like the
simplest thing it's like a hello world
type of an application with me
but there's no linux kernel
so they're going to say cisco 13 that's
not a thing
so then we would
grab it and then redirect it
so wsl one was a big left hand right
hand broker
they would say oh that syscall maps to
that windows kernel call
that's cool
except when this syscall maps to three
or four
kernel calls or this three or four
kernel calls maps to
one on the windows side because the
mapping was not clean
it was still pretty darn cool but then
there was the obscure assist calls so
like we got 80 working and then 90
percent working and then 95 working and
everyone liked it and wsl one was a
success
uh and then some people would try it and
they'd say have you tried wsl i think oh
it's crap didn't work with my app
well why not it works with my app well
it's because they were using an app that
made some system call that was one of
the ones we didn't map and then each
version got a little bit better but for
the most part it's like okay we've got
99 of them so then for people that it
worked for they'd say this is great it
works great
and for other people they would say it
doesn't work at all it's trash because
it only takes one to not work
now processes on windows
have historically been heavy this has
been this way forever this is just part
of the operating system design of
windows and windows nt
the cheapest thing that you can do
on windows to do extra work is make
another thread
the cheapest thing you can do on linux
is make another process
that's because linux processes don't
really think about windowing they don't
they never they were not thinking about
putting buttons on the screen
so if you have a linux process and you
want to just make another one you fork
the process it's incredibly cheap
micro seconds it's like that
but on windows every process
has
windowing behind it it expects that it's
a window even invisible apps think that
there's a window so forking on windows
is like 10x
like an order of magnitude slower
so they made these things called pico
processes let me go back to my notepad
and picot processes are
tiny processes because if we were going
to map one process on linux to one
process on
on windows we would still be 10x slower
so every time the linux elf binary makes
a call it goes to the windows kernel the
windows kernel does the work and then a
pico process would show up in task
manager so you could look in task
manager you could see bash
or you could see vim
but it wasn't a windows executable it
was a
linux executable okay i'm giving you a
lot of background because this is what
you want right you want the internals
and if you all know this or again if i
make any mistakes correct me it's
important that we get this right
okay
so
then people get confused
and people of all ages and all skill
levels about
the difference between a shell a prompt
a console and a terminal
and then they use those things
interchangeably
they say i use cygwin
that's fine i don't need wsl you know
what cygwin is anyone familiar i'll make
sure some people are not i want to make
sure that everybody follows along
so someone will say
or i use con emu i don't need wsl so
let's talk about these things so cygwin
a collection of gnu and open source
tools that provide functionality
similar
to a linux distribution on windows
similar
simulated
c is a lovely portable language and you
can compile c across any operating
system so the gnu utilities and what
does gnu stand for
gnu's not unix
which makes it a recursive
acronym
gnu's not unix they've recompiled
the linux
utilities awk
said vim
against windows itself
so it's a simulation
so i can install that
on windows
i wanted to give you all like the real
deal so let's go to the terminal
we'll make it large
win get search
sigwin
love that high quality wi-fi here
so it looks like cygwin is not up in uh
in wingate so we'll go and run a random
executable from the internet what could
go wrong
this is fine
you know you're on like the 1990s
version of the internet when it's like
the signature
can be used to verify and i just said
yes to an anonymous
unknown object on the internet so that's
gonna be that's probably over for me now
i'm dead
is it running what's happening
okay i just installed a virus
publicly
so what's the deal dude are you running
or what's up
looks like it ran i said yes
pretty sure i said yes
maybe i'll say yes again no
what's
happening install
all users
yeah that's fine
that's fine whatever yolo
available download site this all looks
very suspicious
we should all we should all be wondering
why we're doing this right now
this generally sucks
no i just want to go back what's
happening all right we'll let that
download
that progress bar is not comforting so
i'm downloading
i'm downloading something very
questionable from the internet right now
but what i want to show you is that if i
i should have probably installed it
earlier wow that's so speedy it's a 9600
baud
that's downloading a bunch of actual
exes and actual dlls so these are going
to be bash.exe
and vim.exe and awk and said and if i
run them
they're going to show up in task manager
because they're windows executables
this is again no disrespect to cygwin
this is trash by the way because this is
never going to work
no disrespect to cygwin it's not linux
why is that important to understand
because we conflate these things it'll
let me run bash scripts it'll make me
feel comfortable it'll let me type ls if
i want to type ls that's fine it's a
sigwin is comfort food
but it is not linux it is a user mode
distribution recompiled now when i say
we conflate
things
i'm going to go here into the windows
terminal and i'm going to show you where
it says
default terminal application
and i'm going to give you a little bit
more history because that's what you
like to hear right
what is the thing responsible for
painting on the screen in that example
application that we made in our heads it
spins through some files it reads the
files and it says console.writeline
console.log whatever what's the console
is that program that i wrote responsible
for drawing pixels on the screen
no it's responsible for taking a string
and returning it to the console what's
the console well on windows it's called
con host
conhost.exe you've never ran conhost.exe
you probably didn't even know it existed
so let's change our default to conhost
by the time we're done
i'm sure cygwin will have installed
now there's three progress bars
so
i don't know what that means
it's comforting to just stare at them so
i'm going to hit the run and i'm going
to hit cmd
and let's zoom in over here okay
this
right here cmd
if we look at this
properties dialog that will look
familiar
right we've all seen this before that's
windows 95 code right there
i remember when we got the ability to
have true type fonts in the console
that's how old that dialogue is
that dialogue sucks so much
that they're like trying to fit extra
check boxes in here and you can tell
that somebody did not want to make it
taller because they probably weren't
allowed to so they just made the space
between the check boxes smaller
right so anytime anything gets updated
in there somebody just
shoves it in as close as he possibly can
if i type dir
what was responsible for that well
conhost is the thing that draws the box
that's a console
if i run
powershell
let's run the blue one
it's not blue
scandalous
color
look at this remember all this nightmare
this is the same thing it's got a
different icon but the same exact
console host is responsible this says
command.exe this is powershell.exe
and they're both outputting strings and
then conhost does the painting so when
conhost got upgraded to give you true
type everybody got truetype for free
now here is a a funny story for my
old people
which is probably me uh if i type dir
s we're going to go through my entire
pro my entire directory
really old windows programmers know that
if you have a log spew like this
the way you make it faster
is you make it really small
did you know that who knew that who knew
that
do you don't know why you know that you
just know that right just like and
what's the fastest you minimize it
because because it takes a lot of time
to do that work
because god help me it's synchronous
it has to paint
and it can only paint as it waits for
the thing so if you start painting all
the disk access stops
i love your face sir is pain you're just
like
what kind of
architectural decision
and no one thought this was a problem
why
history uh history
backward compatibility
just historical context i mean this is
the console from windows 95 and it's in
windows 11. it sucks
right
but to go and redo that is challenging
and people people [ __ ] on microsoft and
people pick on them for a lot of things
but tell you microsoft does not get
credit for backwards compatibility
with with apple
they're like surprise your mac is never
going forward to the next operating
system you're stuck i've got a mac mini
it's been stuck on slo snow leopard from
2003 because one day they just said nope
we're going to abandon everyone from
there right but you can run visi calc
from 1979 on windows 11. like they're
obsessed because if we break something
in conhost we break it for a billion
people
there's always somebody out there
counting on a window handle or calling
an api that they're not supposed to and
then we find out that oh we changed this
little thing in conhost what's the big
deal
you broke all of the coca-cola machines
in mexico
because some programmer was looking in
memory for something and made an
assumption and you broke it so that's
literally the kind of stuff that i'm
talking about
so
this is stupid you see how it's still
actually going what a nightmare
all i did was ask for a directory that
has like a maximum of like 30 frames a
second or something
so there are now two
console hosts
there's the windows console host and
then the windows terminal can act as one
the reason that there's two is because
if we broke it then you can switch it
back
okay
right now we have about 98
compatibility which is great but that
breaks it for 2 million people
because a lot of people use windows so
you got to know about this kind of stuff
because it's super interesting
so now
if i go and say
windows r type cmd
that's going to launch
the same exact command.exe
into a different console host in this
case it's terminal
cool
and now terminal is going to be
responsible for painting except terminal
is written from scratch
it's written in like directx and it's
written in c plus it's hard to the metal
it's asynchronous it does like a
thousand frames a second and it's a
whole other thing and it will work
ninety-nine percent of the time 98 of
time unless unless you
the console writer are doing something
weird doing something internal
so already
you can see that that thing's just
ripping along it's going to go as fast
as my system can go
not lovely
that's really really freaking fast
it's even cooler it can do things like
rectangular selects
there's a ton of cool stuff that it can
do
now i've pissed off the whole thing i
should don't rectangular select when
you're looking at your entire hard drive
that was probably a mistake
and it also has this drop down here
this drop down does discovery so it will
look at your hard drive and if it sees
other
other
prompts too many other shells it's hard
i've got to get the language right
myself if it sees other shells it'll
detect them
okay so it detected
developer prompt for vs22 and developer
powershell because visual studio put a
plug-in for terminal and it detected
those so windows powershell is the
classic one that came with windows
command prompt is the fake dos that's
been with windows forever
powershell came from the windows store
that's powershell seven and then ubuntu
we're going to talk about when we get
into linux and then the other two were
detected now sigwin i can add to that
that list
if it's ever going to install
this is just really special
um
we'll we'll look at that another day
imagine a world where cygwin appears in
here
if you go and run bash.exe with cygwin
it's going to be a console app so it
requires a console host to pa to paint
its strings
here's where things really get
interesting
they were so offended by the console
host the original the original crappy
one
uh and its support for ansi and ascii
you know color
and vt 100 and terminal stuff that they
made their own
i think it's called like
min
tty okay and it is its own terminal tty
is a teletype machine or a terminal end
of something i'll show you that in a
minute
so min tty
is the sigwin terminal emulator
again visiting these websites is like
going to the the 90s
and it has full extern support secondary
fonts all these kind of things emoji
yada yada yada it's a vote of no
confidence against the console host
most of the things that they support are
obscure
i'm not saying it's bad or good i'm just
trying to be very dispassionate about it
i'm not trying to sell you anything all
these things are open source so i don't
care if you use them or not i just want
you to know from an educated perspective
why these things exist you with me
so
before they could have cygwin which is
the collection of tools that fakes linux
they needed a way to paint them reliably
because you might run vim on our console
host and it might look weird or a
an emoji might appear in the corner or
they might try to paint something and
it'll it'll be the wrong location
so min tty has better support
it's a different thing that paints on
the screen
there's this thing though
called the pseudo console
in linux that was never supported
on windows
until
we made it
in 2018
come on internet
we introduced khan pty
there's a whole really really
interesting history of the command line
talking all the way back to how these
terminals this is dennis ritchie of sea
fame on a teletype
so these original terminals would send
ascii on the wire
we heard about remember this
ask
ascii 10 and ascii 13 this morning
carriage return in line feed
those get sent serially across the wire
and those would tell it to
feed a line feed a line
or return a carriage
and on windows we would have dot matrix
printers so we would have a carriage
return a lot but on linux they only use
line feed because they just wanted to
feed the line and there's no carriage
here
so these would accept text input buffer
the input put it on the serial line and
then display it
and back in the day
you might have a terminal like this
that would speak a language called vt
220 or vt-100 these things still exist
today when i checked in on the plane in
2022
i could peek and see what they were
using it was a windows machine
running a text box
you've seen these and it was running a
text based gui that was probably a
terminal into a mainframe somewhere
right the windows machine was really
just a host for that kind of stuff
the modern
stuff that you would see for that would
be like midnight commander anyone use
midnight commander
i love i'm going to the archives here
kids
let's see if i have midnight commander
win get search
midnight
there we go
grab it
win get install midnight commander
you everyone use win get
if you see if and is this the first time
anyone's seen winged like what's that
what is he doing
so first time now you're going to be
using it it's great yeah so win get is
like apt-get for windows hence the name
and then what it does is
it has a
oh midnight commander's already
installed okay cool
oh yeah
oh yeah
yeah
everybody likes midnight command
remember that
yeah i remember norton commander
well it was called norton commander when
norton wrote it
uh this is uh you know who wrote this do
you who knows who wrote that
miguel de
acaza yeah
yeah
not just mono he wrote a bunch of stuff
that was written by miguel
and he wrote a really cool thing if
there's any c sharp people in the room
uh called gooey dot cs
check this out
gui dot cs
console based
user interfaces in c sharp
yeah
is that a good feeling or is that like
was that a shudder of excitement or was
that a shutter of like no not again
it's happening again
why
did you just say why
i will tell you why
here's why
this is me writing a blog post called
it's 20 20 and it's time for text mode
and here's one from 2004
windows is completely missing the text
mode boat
i'm telling you why because it's fast
it's freaking fast it's stupid fast it's
never touched the mouse keyboard fast it
paints fast there is nothing faster
no no amount of
um
there we go bring that back no no amount
of of uh ex hardware acceleration
buttons with
with uh 3d shadows is going to be faster
than freaking midnight commander baby
so if you're making a terminal that
someone is going to use only their their
keyboard on and they're going to move
around they're going to move around
faster in text mode
text mode is great especially the amount
of communication sent on the wire is
really minimal and writing these in c
sharp is super fun
so
back to uh i think it's hilarious by the
way that this thing is still installing
anyway
yeah
so this is running in the context of
windows terminal okay
so he's positioning his cursors and his
stuff around the screen you see that
moment right there
you see that
so what's going on there
what's happening is
let me make it larger
see how there's a flash
we're negotiating with the text mode
about how many columns and how many rows
there are and that's all being done with
like ansi art
anyone do bbs's bulletin board systems
yeah my old friends here love you guys
ansi art
looked like this
and you said ascii
are you correcting are you who said that
so you call it you call it ansi i think
this is antsy art you rob you say it's
ascii art
ascii art uses letters right so when i
was uh when i was a wee lad we would do
antsy art that's me ascii art which
would be x's and o's and stuff and we'd
print them out on like foldable paper
and then we'd paste them up and we'd
have like a picture of mr spock she had
to stand on the other side of the room
and squint
and it was just black and white
and then antsy is what is printing out
like that's one character right there
and that's another character you print
half characters and if you look at the
actual code you'd see like a carrot and
then a code that switches the color and
then the character itself and then you
switch back to the other color so this
is allowing you to send these things out
the original windows console host
doesn't you do any of this stuff
it doesn't look right so a great deal of
work was done in the windows terminal to
support
ansi thereby supporting backward
compatibility and giving us the kinds of
expectations that people have there we
go here's some a that's some ascii art
right so we see the difference there
so if i want to do something like this
and i want to draw lines like that that
are smooth and attached then i'm going
to need to use characters that i would
not ordinarily have
okay yeah oh yeah i got menu i forgot to
show you that we got menus too
oh this is another great point look at
this friends
i'm using the mouse
right in order to pick these things so
that is also mouse support that's in the
terminal
all of that needed to exist and be
supported before we could bring you
linux
so it's complicated like
often when you see things like this or
we had that conversation before about
cygwin people like to put the word just
in front of stuff oh
you just you're just running linux on
windows well there's a lot going on here
right we've been working on this
for like six years
and it's like oh we'll just run a
virtual machine oh w cell's just a
virtual machine with linux on it right
there was the pseudo console the
architecture of the pseudo console the
ability to have ansi and ascii support
all the way up
fonts the whole thing so we go back to
our article
about
the software terminals and the
separation
of that synchronous painting out to the
screen
how this terminal the console stuff
works the entire architecture of that
now brings me to
what would old microsoft do
they would come out with a terminal say
that's the terminal
and then they would kill
connie mu and min tty and on and on
there's a whole ecosystem of things we
don't want to kill
cygwin it works
con emu anyone use con emu great little
yeah a couple people back here we don't
want to hurt them
so what we do is we make an interface of
console application services by which
they can then call that so now the new
versions of con emu and hyper
and console z these are on x term these
are all consoles that are part of the
third-party console ecosystem on windows
any one of which you can do i want you
to be able to run bash in whatever
terminal makes you happy
right
i like this one you could use kanyemu
everything works the same so these apis
are all open to the public and they
needed to exist before we did these
other things
okay
so
back to our man you just are just
winning at life right now there segment
okay so wsl
was not did not have a linux kernel it
only ran user mode stuff and it was
super fast on the windows file system
why was it super fast in the windows
file system because they were little
tiny windows processes that makes sense
a lot of people talk about performance
issues with wsl as it relates to file
systems we're going to get into that a
little bit
the better question rather than
memorizing well if you use this on that
file system and this and that but is to
understand the why
wsl are really windows processes
therefore they will be fast on the
windows file system
wsl 2
uses a utility virtual machine
so then this is where we start saying
words like just and i don't like saying
just in software because it minimizes
people's work
you all are working on cool stuff at
work and if you told me about your cool
thing at work and i said oh that's just
and then i named another product you'd
go it's kind of my life's work
thanks right you'd feel sad
you've been able to run hyper-v vms for
years
right you've been able to run hyper-v
virtual box
vmware etc these are all hypervisors
what's good about them
they let you run other operating systems
what's bad about them they're heavy
hey here's a virtual machine 30 gigs
plop right
boot it up okay let's wait 15 minutes
and then you end up with a square
inside your square
right here's your host and here's the
virtual machine inside it and then we
try to hide things we try to make it so
you can drag and drop from the inside to
the outside or the outside the inside
parallels does this really great on a
mac it goes out of its way to lie to you
to make you feel like you're not really
running a virtual machine other problems
with virtual machines for this solution
are that it doesn't work on windows home
that would suck if you had to buy
windows pro just to run linux so we went
out of our way to make sure that you
didn't need hyper-v
to run wsl
here's where it gets confusing because
microsoft
if you go out to the start menu
type in features
you go to turn windows features on and
off and you get to this dialog box from
the 90s
you've got
that which you need to turn on
you've got
these two things
and i don't know the difference
and then you've got hyper-v proper
hyper-v
is like a meta checkbox it's the
install everything i need including that
ugly hyper-v client thing that lets you
manage your virtual machines
the hypervisor platform sits underneath
that but all you need for windows
subsystem for linux is virtual machine
platform and wsl itself
and that works on windows home that
works at your house now today and that's
cool because kids that are in university
are going to want to run bash
now they can and it works great they
won't have the ability to run full-blown
hypervisor type stuff this still uses
the hypervisor and the
the vt extensions to intel and amd but
they don't run
you know full boxes but it's cool
because it works
so when we say utility virtual machine
we want to be able to create a small
fast vm that starts up quickly that has
a real linux kernel
i don't know how to spell kernel
kernel kernel it's one of those
i don't know
okay
when okay wsl
linux kernel
there you go
there is the source code for the linux
kernel that microsoft uses on your
machine
this is really important it's a real
linux kernel it is the linux kernel
it's got some little herbs and spices
that they've added in it to make it work
better on windows but it is linux forked
and followed
and then it's got a little spice and
i'll show you that spice in a little bit
okay but it's important that you know
that that's there so you can go and see
it and compile it even better
you can swap the kernel out yourself so
it's literally a linux kernel on a file
in windows system 32 and if you don't
like it and you want to hack on it you
can write your own and replace it
it's definitely not your grandparents
microsoft
any questions so far
all right this has been going on for a
while
four years ago we started this
so if we come out here
and i'm in
uh fake dos
and when i say dos i mean like you know
dawson quotes and i can type dir and
stuff like that if i type wsl
i immediately have a prompt right here
see how fast that was
one one
thousand
okay
lsb release dash a
that's ubuntu 2004
that's not microsoft this is important
that's not microsoft's ubuntu
that's ubuntu ubuntu from them
now remember all that conversation we
had about the difference between kernel
mode
and user mode
the ubuntu that we're using is not
shipping the kernel
it's the user mode file system for
ubuntu
[ __ ] up
that means zipped up
[ __ ] up
and then simply downloaded via the
windows store
they stick it in the windows store we're
just using the windows store as a
content distribution network
otherwise we'd stick it on github
and then it untars
and then it uses the kernel that we
already have
the kernel is the windows kernel for
security reasons the the windows linux
kernel
and it gets updated automatically or you
can run
wsl-update and it will update for you
you don't really have to do anything
about it we've recently put a preview of
wsl in the store
in the past you'd have to run windows
update to get updates to wsl
now you can just get it from the store
itself which means you don't need a new
version of windows to get new features
so we're actually adding new features to
wsl
from the store but i want you to
understand the separation of those
things it's super important to
understand that you saw how fast that
started that's not a vm the way you
think of a vm now if we go to the store
and we literally search the windows
store for linux
does it all make you feel dirty
don't you just like am i supposed to be
here i just feel a little bit
questionable whenever i do these things
you got kali linux there's the linux
preview i was telling that you can just
install this over the top of the one you
have
you've got sousa you got all these
different linuxes i could go let's
install a linux actually
i think we've got alpine and we got
oracle linux
is alpine in here
alpine
alpine wsl so i got two ways that i can
install this i can push install
or i could do it from the command line
so i could literally push install
but i'm going to be at the command line
and type wsl dash dash list dash v those
are the linuxes i have running right now
docker installs its own i'll explain
that to you in a second
ubuntu is marked with a star that's the
default so when i type wsl i get ubuntu
i can get whatever one i want but that's
the default
i can say wsl dash dash install
and i think it's or is it w cell install
let's see
ah
go back
ah crap
is it
dash d
thank you
i always you know there's like dash
install and dash dash install and 1-2
install dash d for distro
alpine
is that right
well now you said there were no is still
how many dashes do you want man
let's go
two dashes are you sure
let's try this
w cell
i don't like dos i'm gonna go to
powershell
because it's prettier and i have a cool
background wcell
it's uh list online
there we go
oh okay
so dash dash install
d
i think i can get alpine even though
it's not listing it alpine wsl
man you suck
maybe i need to get it maybe only
certain ones are here i'm going to try
anyway
so i could say
install dash
debian
and they would go and get that i don't
know why alpine's not showing up in the
list it's probably not like officially
allowed or
something let's go and see
where alpine is
something i'm going to have oh here it
is
it's untarring there's the tar see up
the top there second line
so it's doing some things
faster than cygwin just saying
just saying
all right
now we're in alpine
okay
go back out here
see
now i've installed a linux it's that
fast
that was pretty fast
now where'd cygwin go
okay
that's a little small
a little small
it's a lot small
ah come on cygwin what are you doing man
this thing you can tell it was written
in in a time of distress
but i want to point this part out here
that the console of cygwin
is not the same one the host is
different
that said though
if i wanted to
there we go
like if i run vim
so i can't have vim
you have vi
defaults to vim okay i mean thanks
let's see if we can see
terminal
that sigwin is installed where
right click open file location
right click
open file location for real
sorry it's small i'll make it big in a
second there we go
just want to make this point
okay those are windows executables
okay
now when we ran cygwin
that means when i
i'm going to close their terminal thing
because it's stressing me out
and i'm going to right click on this and
i'm going to say open file location and
i'm going to look at this at the
properties
and i'm going to look at the target and
open that up in notepad to make it
larger
okay
so it looks like they're running this
thing mntty
so that probably means i can run that
down here
and that's going to default to some
stuff and i can go in here and figure
out
what does it really mean like what are
we running for real
and could i add that to the windows
terminal
you follow
so i'm going to right click and say open
file location and i see a
is there a bash in here
here's a bash i'm going to right click
on that and say copy as path
we'll come out here to fake dos
where's fake dos there we go
i'm gonna paste that in okay
so i just went from fake dos to cygwin
so now i know how to run that
so then that means i could go into
windows terminal hit settings say add a
new profile
new empty profile
name it
sigwin
sigwin command line
i betcha i'm guessing here i've never
done this
starting directory i don't know
save
this might work
could crash everything who knows
maybe i maybe it is crashing everything
i may have broke something
you mad at me what's happening
what's happening
all right i have no idea let's try
go away
okay here's cygwin appearing in the list
ah you see how alpine just showed up
got detected
you go
so cygwin doesn't know
that it's running in a different thing
it just outputs strings but you see how
it's color it's outputting ansi control
codes which terminal understands
so that means that if you use like
anaconda or python or whatever you can
put whatever you want in here now i just
got alpine up to appear
and we saw that over here when we said
wsl
dash list sv
so i can say now wsl wsl-d alpine
and run it immediately or i can pull it
up from here
now because i'm using the windows
terminal i can hold down alt with one
finger
and click on these things
so now
i'm just doing that multiple times
we've got ubuntu
we've got alpine
we've got dos and we've got powershell
all in windows terminal
okay
then i can hit alt
enter and go full screen
and pretend windows doesn't exist
then i can hit w control w
control w control w control w
because i've gone into windows terminal
and i've mapped control t for new tab
and control w which are the things i use
in my browser window to open tabs and
close windows and i map them in here
nicely as well
so if we go back into ubuntu
and we type in df
we can actually see the file system
we see a couple of interesting things
here the most interesting thing is here
mount
c remember at the beginning of the
conversation we said that wsl one is
really fast because they're windows
processes talking to the windows file
system on wsl 2
if you are talking to the windows file
system you will be sad
it will be about 5 to 10x slower
because you're talking to a mount point
to a remote drive that runs a different
file system
it's not the same file system you can
think that that's a limitation yeah
they're going to do the best they can
but they're probably only going to be
able to get it about 30 percent faster
but if you write to the linux file
system which is up there at the top
you're writing in fact to a hidden vhd
which means that you're bypassing ntfs
you're bypassing defender
and you're running at full speed it's
within three to five percent of native
linux
speed so your first like thought
might be when you get this you're like
oh i've got bash i've got i've got vim
like i've got all the things i want to
do so i'll go to c
users
scott
desktop
and then you know party
get clone go nuts right
but what's wrong with that
it's going to be firing off changes to
one drive every time i hit something
it's going to be fighting with ntfs all
of my linux files are going to be
looked at by defender or whatever all of
that's complicated
so what you want to do is you want to
stay on
the linux file system
so i've put my source code here
so here's my website
i keep typing dir
okay
now here's where things get weird
remember how i said that there's some
special herbs and spices
in our in our kernel
you all know
because you're programmers that if you
run vim you can't exit ever you just
have to shut the computer down right
this is just part of world but now you
can just shut down the virtual machine
here's where we offend people you're
either going to be offended or you think
it's amazing or you're going to think
both
and a mumble went to the crowd
is this being recorded i hope not
because somebody's like this is [ __ ]
microsoft you suck
you know they made it 52 minutes into
the talk and then that was that was that
was when they broke me and then
hanselman ran notepad from linux and i
was like that's unacceptable
if you run a dot exe
here's the little herbs and spices
we have the windows path
in your linux path
huh
yeah it's nice yes
and if we see that mz mike matthew
zawinski's name or whatever we go
i can't handle that i'll let windows
handle that
isn't that freaking awesome
like why not
okay
so then we had to update notepad
remember how i said that we didn't just
do anything
there was a cast of thousands involved
in this stupidity this is amazing so we
won't mess up your files okay
so now what if we did this
what
we actually run a plan 9 server and it's
your local machine so it doesn't go over
the network
you have access to your linux file
system from
windows explorer
why not
because it's awesome
right how freaking cool is that
remember when i said at the beginning
that you can run a square inside another
square
does that feel like there's any squares
involved it's completely blurring the
line between what's possible and what's
not possible
so then why don't we just put a freaking
tux
in windows explorer we did
thank you very much
so now if i click on the linux talks
all of my linux distributions appear in
windows explorer
yeah that's good
okay so then what if i run.net
on this machine and i run it run to run
my website
that's going to start up on localhost
who's local host what is localhost what
is life anyway right we live in a
society nobody knows what's happening
cats and dogs living together
mass hysteria
what's localhost
who's localhost local to what
what is localhost means it means your
computer
but this is another computer it's a
virtual machine so microsoft really
works hard on this and the developer
division dev div where i work works on
what's called the principle of least
surprise
right
i'm not joking this is a real thing when
we have conversations about what would
the customer expect what would be the
least surprising thing to do
right uh we also do a thing called the
pit of success
when when the customer falls they fall
into the pit of success
so
they're going to go and they're going to
click on this by the way you notice that
it underlines when i put my mouse over
it
that's new too windows terminal that way
i can click on it right
so now it's hit localhost
that's interesting let's run
tcp view
from cis internals
and look at our ports
you see that
remember how there's a kernel involved
here
but it's got to deal with another kernel
when you listen on a port on a computer
you get one port and one process
so that means we've opened up a port
5000 5001 but it happened inside linux
we wouldn't want someone to hit
localhost 5000 on the outside and get
confused we couldn't open another port
there so we have a wsl host hold that
port open and it port forwards
transparently
so localhost is your computer that box
right there
regardless
isn't that cool
yeah that's the least surprising thing
that would work
it works really really well that means
that i can
run my application my node app my ruby
app or whatever and as soon as we see
someone bind to a port like that we make
it available to the outside but the
outside is just my computer
which is really cool all right
when i run h-top i can see all eight
processors on my machine and all the
memory that i want because it's my
machine there's a config file a hidden
config file you can set to decide how
much memory you want the
system to use and it will grow or shrink
depending
so right now it's using a lot of memory
because i'm running docker
but ordinarily it only uses about 400 or
500 makes and it grows and shrinks
appropriately
so then
what would be an incredibly amazing and
stupid thing to do
let's install the [ __ ]
on ubuntu 2004
how to install the [ __ ]
google in with bing
okay let's go over here i'm just going
to copy and paste whatever
the internet tells me to copy and paste
because that's what you do
just copy paste from the internet
this is fine
what could go wrong
i'm running apt-get update
that's not too bad installing a bunch of
stuff when people go on the internet and
they're like following instructions and
they have a windows machine and then it
says hey you want to install this thing
go to your terminal and then they show
the dollar sign
and the windows person says my thing
looks like a c colon
and they don't feel included
now you can just do that with these
things work you want to install redis
you want to install [ __ ] do it it works
just fine
the other the other cool thing is that i
can go and run applications on linux and
i can
i can work on them on windows i can work
on windows and target linux and do all
kinds of stuff
while this is coming up here
i'm going to open up another
ubuntu
over here
running simultaneous i'm going to go
into that folder hanselman i'm going to
type code dot instead of explorer dot
visual studio code starts up
in the corner you can see it says wsl
ubuntu
if i hit ctrl
tilde tilde
that gives me a terminal inside of
visual studio code for linux
if i say control
o for open to open up a new file
that's the linux file system
i can now in windows in a windows app
work on my application
and this on the local or the
linux file system and when i hit f5
i'm debugging from my windows app over
to my linux app i can do this in visual
studio proper as well
so in visual studio senior
i can hit f5 and debug as well
the other thing that i can do
is i can run docker
so let's close this one
the [ __ ] was going really fast and then
it got slow there inside last last
second
and we'll go over to our
github
folder
and i'm going to say
docker build
and now i am
building in docker
docker on windows uses the linux
subsystem as its underlying platform so
that docker
distribution that we saw is docker's
little partition it's little space so
now i've got my application completely
built on docker and i can also click a
check box and run kubernetes as well
the [ __ ] is not going to work very well
right now because the internet here
sucks
so instead i'm going to click on
let's go and say
apps
u
and i'm going to open up
where did that one go
here we go here's an app
in my start menu on windows
when you install a gui application with
wsl we put a tux over it in the windows
start menu and detect it automatically
and then when i click on it
it starts up
full speed
so this is a get application
that lets me look at my git
tree
you saw how fast that started
so i can look at the
history of my application
the [ __ ] would start just as fast you
see how it looks like a linux
application because it is one
that's a local file system how do you
think that's so fast what's going on
there
any thoughts any guesses
well we got explorer working by doing
that local file system thing we just
made it a file system and explore it and
look at it
that's a local remote desktop
remote desktop is hardware accelerated
3d hardware accelerated
that means i can run like if i wanted to
theoretically emulators
like i can run the dolphin emulator for
a nintendo 64 at 60 frames a second this
isn't like slow
rdp like back in the day
that is hardware accelerated and we have
a separate distribution that manages all
the hard stuff seems like something you
could break or mess up really easily
sound works out of the box 3d
acceleration works out of the box all of
that's done in a hidden distribution
so you've got your ubuntu linux
distribution and then all of the hard
configuration stuff is pre-set up in a
hidden part hidden partition that you
can't mess up
and it's super fast as you can see
right and this is the you can see that
you can see the difference actually i
don't know if you can zoom in or not but
you see how the mouse changes when i get
in there
see how fast that is
it's pretty sweet
so all of this is in my opinion made i
like windows i like the windows desktop
i like windows 11. i like my hotkeys i
know where everything is
but now i can go and target
on azure or whatever
dot net i can pay 30 percent less
because there's not a windows tax i can
put things in containers i'm learning
more about kubernetes
if you're a mac person and you're
wondering what the what the hype is
about
you can run linux on windows and it runs
really really really well
any questions we are four minutes over
what happens if i run
yeah that's a good question so the
question is what if he wants to run code
by installing it in linux
[Music]
yeah so you'd be in linux running a
windows app pointing it to the mount
point
that would probably be a bad idea
let's find out i would probably not do
that
i think at that point you're asking for
trouble
think the first question is why would
you want to why would you want to do
that so i'm in the mount i'm in linux on
the mount point and you want me to do
that
okay so it starts
yeah it's like don't well do you trust
it
it says don't do that
so
then my my answer my question to you
would be
do you hate yourself
or do you want to learn more
yeah don't do that is the answer to that
question i think the the point that the
gentleman is making is a valid one is
that we are going out of our way to tell
you don't do that
if you choose to do that you will be sad
so yeah don't do that
i don't know why everyone
is moving so slow right now but uh yeah
our internets won't work the [ __ ] is uh
photoshop for linux
and it runs full speed and it's great
it's fantastic good question
that's a good question uh let's go here
first
oh there's another great question so if
you're in vs code
and you use wsl vs code will prompt you
to install
different extensions
like remote containers remote ssh that
remote thing opening a remote
isn't specific to wsl so if you're using
raspberry pi's and you have ssh into the
raspberry pi you could develop on
windows ssh into the pi
or any remote linux system it's not
specific to wsl
and then if i go and say
open workspace from file or something
like that there's a section here
where it says well i want to open it
from a container i can do development
inside a docker container i can do it
from
ssh or from wsl and wsl will notice that
you're opening something in wsl and say
let me reboot and start up again and
what it does is it splits visual studio
code in half
which is a good thing so extensions
check this out
let's go back out
and let's go
ubuntu
make the font bigger
hanselman
code dot
okay i'm going to go back out here i'm
going to open another ubuntu to make the
point
and i'm going to hit
h top
i need to fix my colors
there it is right there
visual studio code
notices that it's never been run before
that installs a server
that does that called the language
the lsp language server
process what's lsp stand for
protocol so the lsp host so when you're
typing your code in rust or go or c
sharp and you type like
foo
dot
and there's a drop down
who populated that drop down
the language server process the language
server protocol host
some host had the context on.net which
is what i know more it's like roslyn
knows what to show you
you see
so that's running over there
so in window in the visual studio code
your extensions live in a host of their
own
so if you click on extensions look
these are the local installed extensions
or that's the one that's installed
inside of ubuntu
so you can mix and match your extensions
and that brings me and we're out of time
to what are called dev containers
which are genius and you want to go to
my youtube and look at my development
work that i did with uh
jan de davalier from um oh my posh
he does his work in go i didn't want to
install go so if you want to work on oh
my posh you clone his repo you open it
in visual studio code it has a dot dev
container folder with a docker file
it describes everything you need
including the extensions that you need
in visual studio code and says hey this
is a dev container
fires up a container builds everything
installs the stuff you need to do the
work and then runs vs code against the
server that runs in the box
that's how code spaces works
it's the same technology the same
concept
visual studio code is a client server
application
every one of those extensions can live
in its own container and be remoted with
these different protocols
not cool
it is cool
it is it is deeply deeply cool
yeah it's fundamentally the biggest
thing to happen in my opinion in
software in a long time because then i
can open up visual studio code to a
remote dev container
and i could have a chromebook with
you know 64 gigs of ram and a 60 16
processor or something like that all
right get out of here i'm sorry i'm
talking too much
[Applause]
you